[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes i'm john connolly spectators
news editor
after penny mordant was knocked out of
the tory leadership race this week one
of rishi sunuk or liz trust will be the
next prime minister
andrew neil james forsyth and katie
balls will join me to give us the latest
on the tory leadership race
the tory leadership race has defied
expectations earlier in the week one of
the contenders liz trust attacked her
competitor rishi sunak over his private
education is there a shifting class
happening in the tory party i'll speak
to fraser nelson
freddie gray writes in this week's cover
piece that trump is back and is gearing
up to run in 2024 but are we ready he'll
be on with jacob halbrun
and finally why is country and western
music so popular in africa i'll speak to
aiden hartley
a spectator subscription is now better
value than ever before as a new
subscriber joining today you'll pay just
one pound a week for unlimited online
and app access in your first year to
subscribe today go to spectator.com uk
forward slash tv offer
and why not subscribe to our youtube
channel click the red subscribe button
at the bottom of the video and tap the
bell icon to make sure you never miss an
episode
five leadership hopefuls are whittled
down to two this week rishi tsunak and
liz trust will now face six weeks of
leadership hustings where they'll look
to win over tour members to become party
leader and prime minister
which of the two candidates has a better
chance and will the conservatives be
able to come back together afterwards
i'm joined now by andrew neal spectators
chairman james forsyth our political
editor and katie balls our deputy
political editor
great thank you andrew katie and james
for joining us on spectator tv
now the field in the tory leadership
election has been whittled down to two
after penny mordent was kicked out this
week rishi sunak and liz truss are now
going to the membership for their votes
um andrew to start us off um what do you
make of the field so far do you think
tour members have been given a good
choice between sunak and trust
well i think most westminster observers
thought it would come down to richie
sunak and
liz trust the right core lessing in the
end slowly but in the end the right core
last round is trusts and in some ways
rishi soon after seen as the
establishment candidate there's actually
less that separates them than the sound
and fury would suggest
and i guess that the debate now between
the two will concentrate on economics
particularly tax because in that area
there are differences between them and
uh but i think it won't just be policy
it also be character and general
attitude i mean it is
somewhat ridiculous that
liz truss
who voted to remain in the brexit
referendum is regarded as the staunch
brexiteer
and richie sunak who voted to leave and
has always been a leader
is regarded with suspicion as a closet
remainer uh so i think that is a bit
strange but i think that speaks to
liz trust positioning herself as the
insurgent
therefore
brexiteers are associated with
insurgents and richie sunak is more the
establishment conservative candidate and
the conservative establishment was by
and large for
remains so i think that's what is being
reflected there
and james it seems that richard cena's
maybe got a bit of a tricky position now
he's doesn't seem to be popular with
members at the moment he's only got what
maybe 10 days before the ballots are
posted out i mean how how difficult do
you think it is for him now to kind of
to come out on top over those trusts so
it is a sprint that he came out top in
the parliamentary rounds but as you say
this round to be more difficult i think
i mean nearly everyone thinks that he
starts behind liz trust among the
members so the question for him is what
can he do between now and the beginning
of august when the ballot papers
go out to change minds and i think
there's a particular importance now on
that on that first bbc tv debate between
the two of them on monday night i mean
there's also a particular importance on
on what policies will she see that comes
out and liz trust did quite a lot of
policy in the parliamentary rounds as
she was trying to to as andrew says
consolidate the right behind behind her
richie's united didn't do as much what
does he do now with the members to try
and and show them what kind of prime
minister he would be because although he
has been the chancellor is obviously the
second most senior job in government
because he has been a minister for quite
some time and bound by collective
responsibility there are a whole bunch
of subjects where we don't know that
much about what he thinks now uh and
having known him for a long time i think
he will want to get across
what he thinks on those subjects in the
coming days
and katie coming from it from the trust
sort of camp angle there
what do you think her strategy will be
now do you think she's gonna sort of
play it safe for the for the next week
or so or do you think she has to do a
bit more than that
so liz trusts had the trickiest path to
get to the final two in the sense that
there were it was i think it was quite
hard work the whole way through she had
to have lots of conversations her and
her team of brexiteers for the reasons
that andrew has outlined trying to
convince them to back her even when she
got key endorsements such as sireella
braveman telling her erg european
research group backers to back trust
many of them chose to go to kenny
badenock and so it meant she eventually
got there but the focus in her team was
very much on mps rather than thinking
too much about uh media she's done her
first broadcast interview uh on thursday
um of the entire campaign and that's
also because i think what is generally
perceived one of her weaknesses is media
and the first debate was tricky for her
and she is in the position where she is
now the front runner now she has made it
to the membership stage she has the most
to lose now she has agreed to do at
least two debates and there are hustings
but i think therefore
where team trusts are going to be most
comfortable is putting out her policy
ideas putting out op-eds and actually
being quite careful about how much and
which media she does so not so little
that she can be accused of hiding but i
think rishi sunaka's keen and his team
are very keen to push him to do a lot of
media to try and bounce liz truss into
doing more they think the way that rishi
cena potentially beats her
is by forcing her to do media liz trust
underperforming and rishi soon have over
performing and and that's attached
you're going to see from that side
and andrew just stick with the policy
for the moment i mean you mentioned this
a little bit at the beginning but the
two candidates setting out sort of
slightly different economic stalls i
think sunak wants to
trust wants to cut taxes straight away
sunak wants to come to them later after
dealing with inflation um do you get the
sense that one has a bit more
credibility when talking about economics
or do you think there's not much between
them at this stage
um the richie sunak has huge credibility
uh when he talks about economics and i
say that not actually agreeing with
quite a lot of what he's done but he's
hugely credible in the matter of
economics whereas you sometimes get the
impression that this trust doesn't know
what the hell she's talking about
and she talks about the bank of japan
and uh
about 30 billion already being within
the existing envelope of spending you
know by the time she gets to that 30
billion it may not be there just look at
the latest borrowing figures
the moment that forecast i think is shot
to hell too
so i i think that that he has more
credibility but they both have big
questions to answer so
liz trust is the candidate of the right
but she's pushing unfunded tax cuts
uh i mean how right-wing is that i
thought you know the right was meant to
believe in fiscal conservatism and
certain money uh and that you had if you
were going to cut tax you had to cut
spending
or to do what maggie thatcher did cut
some tax income tax but raise i mean she
doubled vat
in her first major budget so
you know i don't understand when we're
already running of what is it a 2
trillion plus national debt and still a
big deficit how it's that right wing and
uh and conservative with a small aura
capital c to uh
to wish to
basically print money or borrow money to
cut taxes i mean even uh
jeremy corbyn wasn't proposing that and
i think that uh on
mr sunak's side
he's got some questions too because
at a time
when the forecasts were beginning to
show
that the economy was slowing down this
year and we've known that almost since
the march budget now the bank of england
then the forecast then showed it was
said it would slow down substantially as
the year went on
and monetary policy was being tightened
with the end of the
quantitative easing and interest rates
beginning to rise at last so monetary
policies tightening was it really wise
to then tighten fiscal policy the way
richie sunik did and to increase taxes
going into a recession is that really
wise is that is that really conservative
either and of course he's had to roll
back on some of that by coming back on
the national insurance to lift people
out of lift the threshold up and to
increase corporation tax but say
there'll be all sorts of alliances so i
don't think he's covered himself in
glory either and i think both of them
have rather serious economic questions
uh uh to to answer in the debate over
the next couple of weeks
i mean james do you think that's why
sunak isn't doing as well with the
membership now that's sort of that hit
to his economic credibility if you say i
mean traditionally the party are of
sound money you'd think if someone's
preaching fiscal responsibility compared
to the last candidate that they'd be
doing particularly well but that's not
the case i mean do you think that's why
i think it is essentially about whether
the tory party are still a fiscally
conservative party or not liz trust
makes much of the fact that she opposed
the national insurance increasing
cabinet but she didn't oppose the policy
that it was meant to pay for i mean
there is a real danger here for the
tories which is if if the state can step
in so that no one needs to sell their
home to pay for their social care costs
as boris johnson says will be the case
and you don't need to raise any money to
fund that
then you know
a is that credible
and b isn't their risk that the tories
simply get outbid by labor that labour
tell people that they can have all sorts
of things and look the tories have told
you we don't need to raise taxes to pay
for these things
and katie how do you think trust is
going to respond to that i mean i know
especially on that sort of charge of
fiscal responsibility i know she
mentioned some of this in her interview
with you
yes and
in the interview the the
first sit down for an interview she did
the contest she laid out her pitch and
you know i picked her well you are
effectively saying you want to borrow
for tax cuts now her response is the
economic growth is the answer and that
would mean that you'll get lots of
things but you're seeing more and more
people saying well what does this mean
for inflation and which economist are
you listening to and it's quite a narrow
pool she has to point to so i think
there will be scrutiny but i think one
of the problems of rishi sunek is he
just doesn't sound very positive in his
message so um i've spoken to mps uh who
ultimately are a little bit skeptical of
some of liz truster's plans to put it
mildly but they worry that the way rishi
scenic has pitched himself in this
contest for saying you know don't
believe in fairy tales which initially
worked quite well for him because he was
at the center of the debate all the
other candidates one was being pitched
against him in the early stages in these
conversations about cutting taxes um now
just reads as though he he use almost
just wants to raise taxes which isn't
what he's saying he's saying he will cut
taxes in the medium term um but i think
it's quite hard when you're going up a
candidate like liz truss to land that
message um and so far and what he's done
and the other problem rishi scenic has
is there is a group who oppose him not
because of his economic message and they
oppose him because of boris johnson many
of whom back liz trust so jacob
rees-mogg nadine doris and and while liz
trust says she's not going to get
engaged in blue and blue you don't have
to look far in her key supporters who
stand behind her in photo ops to find
those who are quite willing to go on the
record and criticize him so i think that
richard c next challenge has won the
economy and how that's landing with the
membership but also his past record but
two i think you keep hearing liz trust
talk about loyalty and i think they do
think that wherever she like can uh you
know experience damaged relations with
the membership is the fact that he
resigned and they think they can make
hay from that
and andrew do you think that sort of
association with boris johnson for both
the candidates it's gonna be a bit more
of a problem not just with the
membership but when then with the wider
electorate whoever gets elected as in
you know both served in boris johnson's
cabinet for a long time do you think
they're sort of going to be sort of
almost tainted with boris johnson when
they finally run against labour
no i don't think so i i think because
either of them would be so different
from boris johnson
that people will come to think it's a
new government
you know john major who took over from
margaret thatcher in 1990
he was so different from margaret
thatcher uh that people did think it was
a new government so when it came to the
general election in 1992 when mr major
was up against neil kinnick
the uh and labor you know time for a
change is the most powerful political
slogan in any election campaign in the
world
but but when it came to the 92 election
two things happened one people thought
there was already a new government in
the poll tax had gone john major was so
different and secondly people weren't so
sure about uh neil kinner whether he was
really ready for prime time he had come
on by leaps and bounds but there were
still huge doubts as to whether he was
really ready to be prime minister so as
a result mr wade major won a working
majority now if the tories picked the
right leader this time and they make a
success of it and the economy starts to
grow again and the cost of living crisis
is behind us rather than in front of us
either liz trusts or richie sunic will
seem so different from boris johnson
that people once again will think hey
there's a new government already and uh
i think a lot of people will have
different doubts but the same
degree of doubts about kyostarma
this time round as they had about neil
kinnick in
1992 so i think they're still
all to play for but whoever wins has got
to do it right they have they've got a
short window now to get it right they
need to be seen to be different they
need to stamp their mark on it they need
to get some discipline back into this
party again to make it look like a
governing party rather than a kind of
substrata of the oxford debating union
so i think it's you know it's a it's a
it's a tough one to do but but by i
think it is by no means certain that
whoever wins is going to lose at all i
think the conservatives still have all
to play for and kierst armour has still
got to put his mark on british politics
and and james it is a big task ahead of
whoever takes over though with the
economy i mean is there something that
might be a bit of a poison chalice now
with you know inflation above nine
percent this week for example
look the new prime minister is going to
inherit three crises a an economic
crisis an energy crisis you look what's
happening this week with nordstrom one
with with the russians turning the gas
back on to germany but only at a kind of
trickle um
and obviously you've got a war in a war
in europe going on um and put on top of
that there is obviously going to be a
lot of rancor and bitterness left in the
tory party from the fact that party has
changed leader three times in six years
just look at how theresa may couldn't
bring herself to clap boris johnson as
he departed from prime minister's
questions on for the last time on
wednesday so it is obviously going to be
a very difficult job for whoever comes
in but i think andrew's analysis is
right is one of the reasons i think the
tories did ultimately decide to change
leader is but the next election
it's an uphill struggle but it is still
winnable for them this is not like 1995
when it was quite clear that tony blair
was going to win and the only question
was how big his majority would be this
time round i think that that you know
but there is still
a chance for the tories of winning
and katie on those blue and blue attacks
do you think they're going to be a bit
of a problem for the tory party
afterwards i mean there's reports today
that trust is going to be stepping up
the attacks on sunac via proxies and so
on i mean how can the party come back
together after this do you think
yeah i mean clearly when labour have
been watching the debates recently
they've found plenty of attack lines
they can use going forward but then i
mean i think things can change very
quickly
and now i think if we're looking ahead
to what's going to be coming up in the
next few weeks i would expect there'd be
a lot more blue on blue i think that liz
trust and richie don't ultimately decide
to step away from doing a third debate
ahead of the final ballots but that was
partly because mps were being really
turned off by how vicious it had become
between the pair and it wasn't really
advantageous for any of them to to go
for that i don't they'll be able to
restrain themselves too much going
forward and i think it's an interesting
one speaking to senior tories i said you
know well hugh do you think's the best
place to win an election um who do you
think's the best place to lead the
government and actually often you get
different answers um so in terms of
uniting the party after this bruising
leadership contest which we i think we
can safely presume is going to become
more bruising and before it gets better
and actually liz trust i think is seen
as someone who perhaps be able to lead
the government more easily partly just
because there's so much venom in certain
quarters of the party at rishi soon act
amongst the boris johnson loyalists and
some of which i don't think is justified
um but that's just they've decided that
this is the person they're going to
blame for what has happened and that
would make it very hard i think for him
in terms of the day-to-day have you
really careful about how he did that but
then the same people who say this say
well but when it comes to the election
would rather have issues sooner we think
that he would fare better for the
general public and the polling points to
this and this is why it's going to be
very bumpy period no matter who takes
over when it comes to those two key
challenges
and andrew on that electability question
i mean for all his faults boris johnson
did do very well in the north of england
in the you know areas we're calling the
red wall the last election do you think
either the candidates can take on that
mantle and sort of construct the same
electoral coalition that he did
no i don't think they can not to the
same extent but then i don't think boris
johnson could have repeated that act to
the extent that he succeeded in 2019 i
think that
that december 2019 election now looks as
sue generous it was a it was a
particular
coming together of various electoral
forces of which brexit was by far the
most important but jeremy corbyn was
also very important too and suddenly all
these red wall seats began to fall uh
the conservative way helped by having
boris johnson uh as the and they lost
all these seats i think that if mr
johnson had stayed and was taking the
tories into the next election he he
would lose a number of these seats he
wouldn't hold on to them all i'm not
saying there'd be a wipeout but he
wouldn't hold on to the extent uh that
he has because
brexit is not the issue it was except
outside the chattering classes you
remain obsessed with it uh of jeremy
corbyn is no more as a leader of the
opposition um and boris johnson
had remained an incredible vote
generating machine but he was now
generating votes among auntie tories
motivating them to go out and vote
against the tories
that's what happened in the by-elections
so he was a reason to vote against the
tories rather than as in december 2019
to vote for the tories so i think it'll
be much more difficult now
in their own ways they're both
northerners and obviously richie sunak
is very much a southerner but he you
know he represents
william higgs old constituency beautiful
constituency in yorkshire it's a very
northern constituency affluent northern
liz trusts as he leads lass and went to
a comprehensive there not not the sink
school she's made out it to be but
actually she was brought up in a rather
pleasant bourgeois leafy suburb and the
school that she went to was actually
quite a high performer it could explain
why she go to oxford uh there so they've
both got northern uh angles that they
can play
but i don't i just don't think
that anybody now look
there is a long-term trend
of which the what happened in december
2019
was a massive jump in that direction i
think that uh
working class and lower middle class
voters in the middle east and the north
do not tend to vote conservative whereas
white collar more middle class more
bourgeois metropolitan voters now tend
to vote labor uh and that trend's not
going to not going to change you see
equivalent trends
in the united states that are upping the
whole demography of elections now i mean
the hue i mean i've just come back from
the united states the huge change there
is this massive move of hispanic voters
to the republicans i mean who would have
thought that just as who would have
thought that all these northern towns
would have gone to the conservatives
they some of them never had before some
of them hadn't for generations so there
are longer term movements in play but i
think the tories whoever leads them will
have to reconcile that they won't do
quite as well in the red wall as they
did in 2019
brilliant thank you andrew thank you
katie and thank you james
class and background seem to have become
one of the main topics of conversation
in the tory leadership race the contest
has been the most diverse in history
kemi bandak was born in nigeria rishi
sooner is the son of a pharmacist born
to punjabi parents went to school at the
exclusive winchester college liz truss
is the daughter of academics and went to
her league's comp there she was awarded
fewer opportunities than sunak she says
how important is class and background to
voters nowadays to discuss i'm joined by
the spectator's editor fraser nelson
fraser thank you for joining us on
spectator tv
um i mentioned in the intro there about
trusts attacking sunak over his
education i mean what role
what role do you think class has had in
this sort of tour leadership race and
what role do you think it will have as
we go on now
i think tories as a species they're a
bit paranoid about social class they do
tend to end up electing etonians as
prime ministers and now you've got
rather than newtonian the chap from
winchester russianic and it seems that
liz trust is trying to use that against
him by betraying herself as a kind of
salt to the earth comprehensive um girl
now this of course has got quite a few
problems for a start liz truss is
comprehensive was a pretty good school
it's produced four mps it's one of the
most best performing schools in england
and i've also got a feeling that most
voters would see them as being roughly
the same sort of upper middle class
political class oxford graduate
and having contests over which one is
the poorer so it would seem like a sort
of bad tory version of of a three
yorkshireman's sketch and not very
convincing
i'm not sure how much this resonates in
the wide republic if people cared that
much about their being posh prime
ministers then boris johnson wouldn't
have won the red wall in the way that he
did
but in westminster is still a big
delineation between state and private
and liz trusts was trying to say to the
mps as she might continue to say to the
members that rishi sunak
might look a little bit uh
different to your stat standard issue
toward the establishment figure but
fundamentally he's cut from the same
upper class cloth i mean that seems
particularly unfair as well doesn't it
considering sunak's own parents one's um
a gp one was a pharmacist i mean yeah do
you think he's been getting a bit too
much flack for his sort of wealth now
rather than his background
i haven't really seen that much like
he's been getting some flack in social
media there was a clip from him um about
20 years ago where he was talking about
the friends which he had and here's the
clip
i have friends who are as a cat friends
who are upper class i have friends who
are you know working class but i'm not a
working class now of course he's been
teased there for saying that he didn't
do correcting himself and that he didn't
have working class friends but then
again that's because he actually
appreciates the working class has got
some meaning and unless he was telling
the truth he ought not to pretend
otherwise on television so i actually
see that as an unusual self-awareness
and um a sign of honesty from rishi
sunek
but i really don't know how many
vouchers cared about that vouchers want
a competence prime minister somebody who
will get them out of the trouble which
the current the country is currently in
and i think that is going to matter way
more than where either of them went to
school
i mean you say that well that in terms
of quality of candidates both did ppe uh
oxford this time do you think
do you think that says anything about
the race
look i guess some people might say they
would have hoped they would have gone
for a slightly more ambitious degree and
not a mickey mouse degree like ppe but
and then again a lot of aspiring
politicians are lured into that course
thinking it will they'll come out and
it's depressing just how many people on
both labor and maturity benches have got
that degree
and i guess to me that underlines the
that both of them just despite where
they went to school nonetheless came out
of the same kind of oxford sausage
machine nava doesn't make them um bad
people richie sunik has got an
incredibly uh high achieving career
behind him they use them he was a
multi-millionaire in his own right and
if he could walk out of politics
tomorrow and go back into finance in a
heartbeat um but again i think it comes
down more to whether you trust either of
them to
do a change of governments to be able to
get taxes down from the 74 year high and
manage the country
a bit better than um boris johnson who
of course was a classicist in oxford
managed it when he was prime minister
do you think i mean do you think this
sort of decrease in the salience of
class is going to become a bit of a
problem for labour as well because you
know they've made great hay in the past
about sort of itonian cabinets and prime
ministers and that sort of seems to be
fading away i mean are they gonna have
to come up with something new there
well if they are in a way sharpening
their attack line and the kirst armor is
saying he would abolish the charitable
status of private schools always a
divisive question in british society but
i don't really think they're going to be
attacking the tories for coming out of
the oxford political machine i mean kyra
starmer could try to do that he went to
oxford as did his shadow chancellor
rachel reeves and his equalities
minister annelise dodds also went to
oxford as did his education secretary
bridget phillipson so it's kind of
oxbridge wars here between these two
parties i'm not quite so sure but labour
is in a position to say that these
tories are all coming out from from the
same place whatever is true for tories
right now is pretty much true for the
labour party and when they have tried to
use class war previously
it just hasn't washed gordon brown tried
this quite a lot and it just leaves the
public cooled it's an obsession here in
our little postcode in westminster but
beyond it's not so much
and if you so you mentioned all the
candidates there sort of come from the
same sort of social media i mean
are we seeing sort of a triumph of the
middle class across the political
parties now to the to the sacrifice of
the working and upper class
well it needn't necessarily have been
this way has kemi being still being in
the running you have in her somebody who
went to you know unlike liz trusts a
pretty un badly performing and state
sixth form she were in worked at
mcdonald's and then worked her way up
from there uh but even then i think that
would have made her exotic in
westminster circles but it was more her
directness but sets her apart from the
other candidates
i do think that when you look at the um
you know the the leadership candidates
in both labour amatory party you do see
a distinct lack of people from
non-professional backgrounds people who
didn't and i look back and i think take
sergeant javid for example now he was
somebody who almost didn't finish school
he was all set to leave school at 16 and
he would have done has it not been for
the um encouragement of a tutor who gave
him free lessons to help him get into a
sixth form from then on to
extra university and from then on to
finance where he became a
multi-millionaire and i think it's the
sasha javid story that's
underrepresented in british politics so
often debates about equality all descend
down to one question who gets into
oxford uh you can understand why that is
an obsession given how many of both from
benches themselves went to oxford
but and david lammy is
he's almost obsessed with them trying to
find out the socio-economic background
of oxbridge graduates but in fact oxford
and cambridge will let in peop
about the same proportion of private
school kids as get top results in a
levels that isn't really the problem the
problem is enlightened the state schools
who finishes school in the first place
who is deprived of their educational
rights during lockdown
there is such a massive equalities
question to ask which goes far beyond
the reindeer games of those who are
groomed for the british elite by the way
it doesn't make any of these people bad
people it doesn't mean they're any less
able to serve the country but when you
do look at the educational background
it's not nonetheless the politics is to
perhaps an unhealthy degree the
plaything of those who have been
prepared for it from their teenage years
i think i would like i certainly would
like to hear a lot greater diversity of
voices and perspectives it's not really
about social class it's just about to
reflect the fact that there's all sorts
of trajectories in this country quite
often we talk about young people and
graduates as being the same thing so we
think you know young people tuition fees
but forgetting the fact that half of
young people don't go to university and
i think a lot more attention should be
put onto them
one of the many questions that we're not
really hearing debated during this tory
leadership campaign and i'm not sure
will be debated after it either
i mean you say that phrase i mean the
tories do have a nice story to tell
though don't they and whoever wins this
time is either gonna be the third female
prime minister or the first ethnic
minority prime minister after israeli um
what are they doing right compared to
labour do you think
i think the conservatives had david
cameron's a-list ten years ago that was
definitely a big factor and cameron
really went out of his way to encourage
promising candidates from ethnic
minorities and women to come into a
party to try to mix up the pale male
stale as you saw it tori format now that
succeeded but what cameron didn't
realize was that these people coming in
were way more thatcherite than the tory
modernizers and that what he was
planning was planting the seeds for the
re-thatcherization of the conservative
party so now you've got russia sunak who
is um writing the daily telegraph um
about how thatcherite is i think he uses
thatcher's name three times in one
paragraph right now and you've got liz
trusts whose critics say that she's
trying to physically look like thatcher
in the way that she she dresses but so
you are getting um of course there's no
doubt about it that the tory leadership
race and white men were in the minority
and you were getting um a tory party
which far more resembles more than
britain now and i do think that's
because david cameron made all those
extra efforts in this election ten years
ago so he should be proud of that but i
think the proudest achievement is the
fact that the conservatives don't really
go around parading their credentials i
don't really think you'll hear russia
sunex saying um you know as a man of
indian origins i think dot dot dot
you're not going to hear less trust
saying as a woman i think dot dot dot
you're not going to see anybody driving
around in a pink bus as labour tried to
when they were trying to um go for the
female vote so i think you're getting
a move beyond identity politics but more
than that you're seeing a conservative
party that defines itself against
identity politics but defines itself
against a mentality that would look at a
politician and see a skin color first
and a person second and to be able to
move beyond that i think is quite an
achievement
um of course i i still go back to what i
regard as the massive unanswered
questions about poverty and inequality
in britain and but when it comes to
representation that is something that
conservatives are doing far better than
labour and that's not by accident that's
because of what david cameron did 10
years ago so that's the reason they can
afford not to talk about it much now
because david cameron did talk about it
back then
and so fraser at the beginning there i
mentioned trust's attack on sunic about
his education um to finish off do you
hope the leadership contest from now on
will be a bit more about a bad love
ideas rather than a battle of
backgrounds and why not being one
yorkshire men in each other i very much
do hope it's going to be about ideas
ultimately you play the hands you're
dealt in life the question is how well
you play it now and liz trust and riches
and i have got so much to discuss about
so much to argue they've got 10 debates
in front of them but the depressing
thing is that the votes papers go out in
about 10 days time so really we're going
to get a very very short meaningful
period of debate where rishi sunik will
have to show us that he is offering more
than elegantly managed decline and this
trust would have to show us that she can
actually deliver some of the ideas that
she is dangling very important questions
neither of them are remotely related to
their gender or their skin color thank
you fraser
remember if you enjoy what we do here at
spectator you can subscribe to the
magazine and to our online content to
subscribe today go to spectator dot co
dot uk forward slash tv offer
is trump about to stage a comeback in an
interview last week he said he had
already made that decision
what would a second run for the
presidency look like and would he win
freddie gray writes this week's cover
piece on trump's return and he joins me
now alongside jacob halbron editor of
national interest
freddie jacob thank you for joining us
now freddie you're writing this week's
cover piece about the return of trump so
i guess the big question starts off is
do you think he's going to run for in
2024
i think he will
i had my doubts before i started doing
this piece and i spoke to a lot of
republicans who know a lot more about it
than i do
and the impression i very much got
was uh why wouldn't he um and if you
look at it from trump's perspective
which is a very weird unique perspective
i grant you
uh it makes a lot of sense um he is the
obvious frontrunner if he stands for the
republican nomination it's hard to see
how anyone stops him and then even if he
wins the republican nomination despite
the fact
he's obviously a very toxic figure in
america
i think he has quite a good chance
of uh winning back the white house so
what what struck strikes me as odd
is that it's a sort of question that a
lot of people um because i've written
about american politics a bit a lot of
people in this country ask me is he
going to run is he going to from but
nobody really wants to know the answer
perhaps because
uh in some very strange way we don't
actually want to know the answer which
is he probably will and he could well
win
and jacob on that on that question do
you do you think trump would win the
nomination and if he goes on and gets
the nomination do you think he'd um he'd
win
i'm
skeptical that he would defeat biden or
another democrat
because he lost the last election pretty
decisively
and i think it would be difficult for
him to come up with a new road show he's
so obsessed
with having putatively not lost the last
election that he is becoming a bit of a
boar
even to some of his followers according
to the latest polling
however there are two compelling reasons
for him to run anyway
one is
that he wants to portray any indictment
as a political act against him he could
be indicted both by the justice
department and in georgia or in new york
or maybe by all three
and the other one is that he really does
crave revenge against joe biden
and the
multifarious difficulties
that biden is experiencing now
including a lower approval rate than
trump ever experienced as president
means that
all the incentives are there in trump's
own mind to give it another go
but you don't think he'd beat biden in
the in the 1v1 with sort of the economy
going down the pan inflation high gas
prices high and all the rest
it would have to be a much worse crisis
than it is now i mean we we definitely
uh the the american public has turned on
biden and on the democrats but it has
not embraced the republicans either
that's the peculiarity of this situation
if you look at the polling the
republicans should be doing even better
the public is essentially disenchanted
with all of the politicians however i do
feel it is incumbent upon me to say that
freddie has done a remarkable even
brilliant job for making the case in his
new spectator piece
for how and why
trump could indeed prevail and it would
be foolish to ignore freddie's case
because people have written off trump in
the past and he has succeeded so i think
freddie has made
a valuable
case for trump and maybe we should
discuss that or freddie can elucidate
upon why he thinks that trump can indeed
triumph go ahead freddie
yeah all right uh yes well i mean i
think uh trump um actually can triumph
and i think the thing that people uh
always overlook
is the size and strength of the trump
movement and the extent to which it is
wedded to donald trump
people don't like it uh it's not always
very attractive uh it is extremely
divisive and toxic and a lot of people
really hate it
but the fact is if you drive anywhere in
rural america today you'll still see
trump signs you'll still see
you'll see trump 2024 signs
there is a very very powerful movement
in america that is wedded not just to
trump's politics but to trump himself
and they do think
probably wrongly on most counts that
there was something wrong with the 2024
sorry with the 2020
election
and people can scream as much as they
like about how insane that is how crazy
that is but the fact is it's a
significant part of the american
population 40 percent uh according to
some polls think there was something
illegitimate about biden's victory the
question is does the 60 percent feel so
strongly that biden was
the righteous victor and do they feel
strongly enough to vote from again
to defeat him again
i was going to say what's so interesting
about about freddie's
piece
is
that
what what liberals don't want to accept
in the united states
is that
even if they view trump as authoritarian
that a good chunk of the american public
wants that from trump
this is not some anomaly
and biden keeps saying well this isn't
america
biden is wrong
this is america it's a significant slice
of it as freddie is saying and you can't
simply wish it out of existence
and freddie we've been talking so far
mainly about trump facing biden do you
think are there any sort of um potential
successes divided on the democratic side
who trump would be more afraid of or or
less likely to win or do you think it's
a pretty pretty poor crop at the moment
as well
well it was interesting so uh one
republican strategist i spoke to said
that if biden doesn't stand
then trump's less likely to stand
uh which i thought was interesting
because the revenge factor would be
diminished there
uh but then i spoke to some people who
who talked to trump and they said uh
no that's rubbish uh one person said no
sane person uh thinks that joe biden is
going to stand again
uh and then he paused and he said well
joe biden is insane so he might
so i think
what you what you'll have is uh
probably joe biden just because of the
lack
of other candidates unless his uh sort
of old age starts to show so badly in
the next two years that just becomes
completely untenable
but the point is is that there are no
good alternatives kamela harris polls
terribly uh generally thought in america
that she
underperforms with all sections of
american society with most sections of
american society
and then you look at the alternatives
you know p bootage is a name that's
often uh bandied around but i mean look
at his run for the presidency last time
he scored zero percent uh in some polls
with african americans uh there are no
credible alternatives and there's nobody
who can really bring the democratic
party together the republican party has
plenty of its own problems i don't think
they're quite as consequential as the
democratic party's problems
do you agree with that jacob do you
think it's a fallow field for the
democrats as well
no i think actually
there is quite a bit of ferment in the
democratic party as we know the
the liberals
the progressives
are up in arms about biden's performance
i think biden has about if he wants to
run for the presidency again which he
clearly does
he probably has
about another nine months to turn it
around
for himself as a party candidate
it it would not be easy to unseat him
but the ques the real question would be
whether he runs at all
if he does not run i think
i don't know harris would obviously run
i don't think she's viable
they need someone
like gavin newsom from california
someone young fresh that the american
public is not that familiar with who has
a successful track record which which
actually california is well run
has
budget surpluses
can present itself which it has
historically in the past been
for the republican party
a both nixon and reagan came
from california and were able to portray
themselves
as a step ahead of the rest of the
country that california was on the
forefront of the u.s now it has become
more associated obviously with liberal
politics
but
if you had a new some desantis
clash in the in 2024
that would represent a generational
shift in the united states
the problem that trump will face is not
that different from the one biden does
we essentially
resemble
east germany in about 1988. we are a
gerundocracy
freddie so jacob mentioned desantis
there i mean do you think he could he
could pip trump to the nomination or or
possibly win if trump doesn't stand
well i think jacob with his uh typical
perspective has has lighted on a very
interesting clash which might be
emerging uh between gavin newsom in
california and ron desantis in florida
because uh if you want to do a kind of
disraelian
uh you know two americas
uh vision of the future you have it
there you have uh newsom the face of
progressive politics an effective
campaigner in many ways who despite many
problems in his state still seems to be
able to win
and you have ron desantis who is
you know trump 2.0 in many ways
a sort of a more machine
politician version of trump
um and you see already gavin newsom
taking out advertisements
in florida
uh attacking ron desantis why would a
governor of california do that there's
no real reason to do it apart from the
fact that a lot of
rich
very often uh
right of center americans are leaving
california and going to florida because
florida is increasingly seen as
california was seen in the 70s and 80s
as the sort of the the part of america
that is free and pos and prosperous uh
and so you have that very interesting
clash there
my piece uh in the magazine this week
suggests that that clash
what i'm trying to say is that i'm not
sure that clash is quite ready to happen
because you still have
this enormous towering presence
of donald trump over american politics
and when you say there's sort of a
general shift jacob
is the idea that desantis would be sort
of a new incarnation of trumpism and
possibly more effective the republican
party the apparatus
and a good chunk of the voters are
yearning for someone
other than donald trump they don't want
to blow the next election they see
that the opportunity is ripe to take
back not just the house and the senate
in the november midterm elections but
also the presidency in 2024. this is why
pence is already out there on the
hustings
he may be even more active in touring
around the united states and meeting
with republicans than desantis desantis
has raised more money than trump in
recent months the signs are there that
trump's support is deteriorating this
does not mean that he is not in control
of the gop which he still is and that's
why freddie's
article offers us a salutary reminder
that we shouldn't simply dismiss trump
but he is experiencing an erosion
and his age his unpredictability he just
called the wisconsin speaker of the
house
a few days ago to demand that he
overturn the 2020 election
the man is to some degree simply bonkers
and out of control
so it is not surprising
that republicans would want someone like
desantis who is far more disciplined
than trump but espouses many of the same
policies and indeed would run to the
right of trump in a primary against him
particularly on the covet issue he would
attack trump for having pushed
the vaccine
as president
and freddie you mentioned your piece i
think the desantis has this sort of same
trumpian ability to shock
um to set sort of the politics of light
but he's not quite up to trump's
standards yet do you yeah can you
yeah what do you think what do you think
is going to happen there
well i think he he doesn't drive people
he he specializes in in making the the
left the progressive left over reach uh
in a way that's advantageous to him uh
he doesn't have trump's completely
unpredictable juju which is a unique
sort of strange phenomenon that nobody
quite understands
i think it's interesting jacob's saying
that desantis could attack him from the
right i think in terms of the republican
nomination that's probably the only way
in which you can hurt trump in fact
people quite close to trump suggested
this could be his
weak spot in many ways is that
particularly nations of vaccines donald
trump wants to take all the credit uh
for operation warp speed and rolling out
the vaccination program but his base is
not at all comfortable with with
mandatory mandatory federal vaccinations
and indeed the vaccine itself so you
could have a sort of
you know wilder than trump a candidate
running against trump on the right
can desantis do this i i think he
struggles just because
trump still despite what jacob says
about fundraising trump still is the the
fundraising uh key to to republican
efforts um if if they put out
a mass email without trump's name on it
uh they raise very little money you put
trump's name on it you raise a lot of
money that may be diminishing it's true
but it is still so strong uh that i
suspect it will last for another couple
of years more at least
brilliant thank you freddie and thank
you jacob
and finally why is country music so
popular in africa aiden hartley the
spectator's wildlife columnist writes in
this week's magazine that african
farmers particularly in the east of the
continent find that their american
counterparts have similar lives to their
own to explain aiden joins me now
aiden thank you for joining us on
spectator tv um you're right in the
magazine this week about anglophone
africa's love affair with country and
western music to start off can you tell
us why why this genre is so popular
there
uh it's a it's a phenomenal fashion that
is sweeping particularly kenya and other
parts of
anglophone africa that would have been
ruled by the british
it doesn't really affect francophone or
lucifer in africa where
uh south american rumba and other types
of music you know have a tradition
but in africa it's been going since
jimmy rogers
came into the continent as a result of
phonograph records
in the 1920s and
it put down very deep roots amongst both
black people and white people
over the succeeding decades
um in south africa i write about how
the afrikaners identified you know
greatly with the
kind of melodramas of the lyrics and the
songs
and and they like the folk tunes
and then in places like uh kenya
uh where my family has been for nearly a
century
um i remember you know the older
generation my parents
um listening to jim reeves and you know
dressing in cowboy hats
and it seemed to be something that for
the whites
potentially it was something that they
they've identified with more because
they were farmers because they were
cattle keepers they lived
a quite a dramatic rural existence um
but also it was something that they
could identify with more than what was
going on in europe and urban america
you know with the rise of counter
culture the beatles the 1960s um and so
it sort of started from those roots
and these days it's not just american
imports is it so there are lots of
homegrown african country and western
stars is that right
well i've been speaking to uh one of the
most famous country singers in kenya who
is called sir elvis he was named elvis
at birth his real name is elvis otiene
and he's been playing guitar since the
age of six
um and he uh has put out uh hits here
one of them i think is quoted in the
magazine called loving man
these are classic uh country and western
tunes
um when he speaks to me it's in a in a
texas drawl
um and and and the themes will be very
familiar to anyone listening to country
and western um at the same time the the
fact is that the the classics are still
very popular here um i write about how
the gambler by kenny rogers is still the
most uh requested song
on radio in kenya and um the the
puzzling thing is that uh the classics
seem still to have an enormous popular
currency in the country i mean you often
hear them on fm radio stations uh
wherever you are in in kenya um and to
an extent this is happening in nigeria
and uh
the country formerly known as swaziland
now called eswatini um it's not all over
africa but but in kenya there's such a
huge following
that uh a journalist and dj that i spoke
to called jeffcoingy he has a big show
that plays every sunday and he takes his
uh smoking country road show
to different provincial towns
and he sings alongside sir elvis and and
they pull in crowds of hundreds and
thousands of people sometimes all of
whom turn up in stetsons and big buckle
belts and cowboy boots and denims
and they line dance and they are devoted
to not only modern african country or
even country that is being sung by black
americans like darius rucker but also
characters like uh
denver and kenny rogers and jim reeves
and dolly parton who is a superstar in
kenya so it's it's a fascinating
phenomenon i mean one of the things
is that these young people many of them
middle class urban kenyans are spending
large sums of money on buying stetsons
online from arizona
and then they also go to these
second-hand clothes markets africa
really dresses itself in second-hand
clothes from the west um something like
four million tons of second-hand clothes
are imported
to the continent each year and in
amongst those clothes you're going to be
able to find all sorts of stuff like
cowboy shirts and denims and so when
they turn up at these conference
concerts they're dressed to the nines
um you mentioned there a bit earlier
about it sort of potentially crossing
racial lines i think one of the people
you mentioned your pieces roger
whittaker was a former sort of colonial
soldier i mean do you think it's sort of
a bit of a healing process as well a bit
of sort of western music here
i don't know that it's that but roger
whittaker was something special he was
born in kenya and during the 1950s mao
mao emergency he joined the kenya
regiment which was a mostly white unit
that fought the mao mao
and his parents were grossers in um
thica just outside nairobi
and he's so fondly regarded by kenyans
that they've given him a kikuyu nickname
which is waitaka instead of whitaker um
he came out with lots of songs
apparently he's very big in germany and
he's quite elderly now but in the 1970s
he came out with a song called mylanders
kenya which is like an anthem and it
speaks to all of us whether we are white
kenyans like me or black kenyans and
they take him very seriously and they
regard him to be a country singer star
in this country um
at the same time i mean when i asked
people like sir elvis you know why is it
that a dominantly white genre of music
that is something that still is
identified as white and plays to white
folk in the united states although it
growing apparently there are more and
more uh black audiences to this music
and singers the the reaction is is one
of puzzlement they say you know this is
music that crosses boundaries it's not
something that we identify with uh you
know the white folk of the states at all
and i think that what it comes down to
is that kenya is still a 75
rural country a lot of people go back to
the farm their families are still in the
village and on the farms
and although society is changing at
breakneck speed and now a lot of the
followers of country and western are
urbanites and middle class they still
have a nostalgia for the countryside and
they still go back to the village at
christmas and easter and any of the
holidays and they still sort of identify
themselves a bit like australians with
you know the bush the texans with you
know the range uh east africans you know
still think of themselves as people who
are connected to farms to cattle and so
you know getting out there sitting on
hay bales and drinking pretty expensive
single malt whiskey is the sort of thing
that they like to do on the weekend i
think it's also because it's identified
as quite a conservative genre and it's
god-fearing and you know a lot of these
lyrics are about one's devotion to god
but it's also about the hardness of life
and you know when i said to them you
know why do the lyrics speak to you
people would say to me but this is
describing what africa's like the lives
of africans
is today you know the
uh coin angie said you know uh four
hungry children and a crop in the field
that's the life of africans but then my
response to that was well isn't that the
same as yorkshiremen or people in the
you know towns of america or wherever
but that seems to be an argument that a
lot of them use that they really
identify with the drama and the
melodrama of of family life and you know
mothers and disappointing sons and death
bed
reconciliations and people who've done
time and go on trains to different
places
yeah yeah i mean it's fascinating by
something like the blues for example in
america which is very much an
african-american american
music movement didn't spread over to
africa in the same way i mean why do you
think that is compared to country and
western i suppose
well um
some of the people i spoke to
identified the sort of great take off of
popularity of country music um as during
the 1960s when uh
jfk kennedy organized what was known as
the airlift and a lot of promising young
east africans particularly kenyans went
to the united states to university and
barack obama's dad
obama senior was one of them and instead
of going to chicago or detroit or new
york or l.a you know they went to small
christian colleges in the southern
states
barack obama senior went to hawaii and
the argument is that they discovered
country music but not motown in these
places um and and that's what they
brought back and uh perhaps they were
regarded as two straight laced and and
and and and conservative really um these
young african boys and girls um i i
think that motown and black american
music has had an enormous effect across
the continent and particularly in south
africa you know the uh early popularity
of country music has sort of died off
but all of the rest of the imports from
america uh are what have uh you know
influenced a lot of the local music and
then you know once again in places like
congo it was cuban rumba and other
strains and tones that that gained
popularity um in in kenya you know is an
amazingly diverse music scene that's
grown up particularly with fm radio and
radio here is still tremendously
important but all of us remember growing
up when there was just the state
broadcaster that would uh put out these
programs on country and western on
saturday afternoons and so
that was the most popular music show in
the country and then once again as a kid
like coin angry and sir elvis i remember
going down to this uh shop and factory
in central nairobi called shankar das
and suns and they were you know pressing
the lps the 33s and the 45s you know
just as they arrived from the states and
people would be spilling out onto the
streets listening to songs by dolly
parton and others
brilliant well thank you very much aiden
and we'll hear some african country in
western to send us off
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's it for this week remember if you
enjoy what we do here at the spectator
you can subscribe to the magazine and to
our online content just join today and
you'll pay just one pound a week for
unlimited online and app access in your
first year to subscribe go to spectator
dot co uk forward slash tv offer and
don't forget to subscribe to our youtube
channel as well just click the button at
the bottom of this video and tap the
bell icon so you never miss an episode
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week
[Music]
you